this great big story was made possible
by the Singapore Tourism Board we try to
push the boundaries of which ingredients
can be used in a cocktail you use and
grasshoppers - kimchi and we've even
used salmon roe in one of our cocktails
we are one of the only bars in the world
that focuses on using ingredients in the
way that we do my name is Vijay Medallia
and I'm co-owner of native wear cocktail
bar based in Singapore that focuses on
working with four ingredients
so I've been foraging for about three
years now as a younger bartender I was
always interested in like unique
important ingredient the environment in
Singapore is quite diverse sometimes we
do a bit of urban foraging we also go
out into the forested areas and we also
go down to the coastal lines to get
things like seaweeds and clams
using some of these unusual ingredients
we can get certain interesting flavors
the forage ends for example contain
formic acid so when you pop them they
taste like little limes or lemons
because of the acidity for grasshoppers
what comes out is dislike me so Vegemite
soy flavor which is a real savory note
to it our cocktail making process lasts
for six months it usually starts from an
idea that is based on a tradition
culture location or the environment for
example our Peranakan cocktail is based
off the local product and culture and
was inspired by one of the desserts
called the Quay salad we use pandan and
laksa leaf from a local organic farmer a
jackfruit Ram so we are using foraged
jackfruit also goat's milk from a local
God's fun the enzymes in the jackfruit
curdles the milk and we get clear
cocktail we try to incorporate those
ingredients they have been used
culturally for over a hundred years
[Music]
what I like about incorporating four
ingredients is that it allows us to
understand our environment a lot better
and to find forgotten ingredients in our
culture hopefully in the next few years
the idea of foraging will feel so new I
think people want to experience the
location and when people are traveling
the world they want to have a sense of
identity at the place where they are